I teach in hopes of turning content into rocket ships,...
...tribulations into telescopes,...
...so a child can see their true potential from right where they stand.
And injustice is telling them they are stars without acknowledging...
...the night that surrounds them.
Injustice is telling them education is the key...
...while you continue to change the locks.
Education is no equalizer.
Rather, it is the sleep that precedes the American Dream.
So wake up, wake up, lift your voices until you've patched every hole...
..in a child’s broken sky.
Wake up every child so they know of their celestial potential.
I've been the black hole in a classroom for far too long,...
...absorbing everything, without allowing my light to escape,...
...but those days are done.
I belong among the stars and so do you, and so do they.
Together, we can inspire galaxies of greatness for generations to come.
So no, sky is not the limit, it is only the beginning.
Lift off.